tu ressembles à regarde à Benoît Magimel
et c'est vrai
je l'adore en plus comme ça
j'ai fait l'intelligence artificielle
regardez mais là il m'a regardé
[Applaudissements]
c'est vraiment
je ressemble à 30 %, ça va à 30 %
regardez Christ Guillaume regardez
Guillaume qui tu ressemble
[Applaudissements]
à 45%
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
Géraldine maillet tiens regarde
il y avait également les chéris
j'ai Gilles
c'est celui qui s'en sort le mieux
Adrian
[Applaudissements]
rien à 35 c'est marqué excuse-moi je
vais te demander juste un truc je vais
te rappeler les règles j'ai draguer les
règles fondamental de la télévision déjà
tu parles pas sur les autres
deux tu souris et tu rigoles quand
Gilles Verdez dit quelque chose vas-y ah
je ressemble à Adrien Brody
ah bah tiens j'ai monté qui ressemble
mon Dieu
65%, 65 Jean-Baptiste Guégon
[Rires]
il est pas mal mais je l'aurais jamais
pensé à lui ouais moi non plus et
j'adore je l'aime bien en plus oui il
est formidable non mais c'est vrai que
j'ai pas pensé toi lui je vois pas le
principe quoi
[Applaudissements]
c'est incroyable j'avais remarqué
tu vas faire
franchement c'est incroyable
alors scarlett Johansson je vous le dis
elle a baissé un petit peu il a raison
dans les belles années Johnson a la
baissée
[Rires]
de quoi mais scarlett Johansson frère
mon père il était avec elle pendant deux
semaines
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
mais sur ma vie mon père en fait je
t'explique l'histoire il devait aller à
Tunis parce que il a la donation
tunisienne il devait aller faire changer
son passeport en Tunisie il arrive à
Tunis à l'aéroport de Tunis tout ça et
là il arrive comme ça ils vont à un gars
qui vient jour pour l'opinion le
chercher tu vois et donc il voit une
deux blond avec tu vois il dit ouais ça
va et donc il regarde c'est qu'il a de
Blond le gars il dit c'est une meuf
scarlett Johansson elle tourne en
Tunisie et donc je l'amène aussi parce
qu'elle va à côté d'où tu vas il y a le
temps de pomme il connaît pas tu vois
ils arrivent et tout ils passent devant
un déficit et mon père il veut manger
des sandwichs au thon
je vous raconte donc il est dans la
voiture à l'arrière tu vois toi il se
parle pas jusqu'au moment il m'a changé
le sandwich au thon bon comme il est
sympathique on va prendre des Sandy
jetons il en prend pour elle d'accord
[Rires]
il lui dit et lui dit il lui dit est-ce
que tu peux me l'enlever Scarlett arrive
elle commence à lui enlever comme un
sloton mon père il a eu du temps dans la
bouche il dit tu kiffes le ton elle dit
oui tu vois pas quelqu'un
sur ma vie et là il se galoche de ouf du
ton tout passe
scarlett Johansson elle arrive sur ton
âge un bouton ici de la Richard
sur ma vie frère ils sont restés 15
jours ils sont restés 15 jours ensemble
au Tunisie et voilà et donc depuis ça tu
vois chez berbeche
sur ma vie que c'est vrai c'est ce qui
te dérange
elle me dit
tu rigoles toi bah oui bah c'est vrai
quoi c'est incroyable quand même
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'est moi qui l'ai fait moi qui l'ai
fait moi-même regardez à qui je
ressemble à 54%
tu es rentré dans les domagos
tu n'en sortiras pas
c'est les commissaires à l'appareil
[Applaudissements]
les gars je me suis amusé à faire ça
hier
j'aime les bonheurs
mais si toi j'ai regarde regarde a
quitté
[Applaudissements]
mais elle avait l'air contente